[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy
estamos con aquiles este analista y
consultor en mercadeo electoral quien se
encuentra en miami florida en eeuu y
hablaremos de las votaciones en
venezuela los resultados de los comicios
legislativos otorgan a nicolás maduro y
al chavismo el control total de la
asamblea nacional la única rama del
poder público que no estaba en sus manos
señor este la primera pregunta y gracias
por estar con nosotros es que pasará
ahora con la oposición juan guaidó y
muchos otros opositores pierden su
carácter de parlamentarios y el
principal foro a nivel interno para
promover sus políticas que pasará
entonces con el proyecto opositor en
general y con la figura de why do en
particular buenos dias saludos de miami
la verdad una gran incógnita no se sabe
exactamente qué va a ser la oposición a
raíz del resultado del día de ayer
contador puso de opereta porque nadie
acepta la elección del día de ayer como
valga a no ser los aliados tradicionales
del chavismo vales de china rusia
nicaragua
la uva
pero bueno es verdad es una gran
incógnita no se sabe qué va a pasar con
web de la oposición en su conjunto no se
sabe si van a ir a la clandestinidad no
queda claro cómo va a seguir el apoyo de
quien ha sido el principal aliado del
valedor en estos últimos dos años
vale decir eeuu
que cuenta ahora con una nueva
administración realizada por job hay de
todos son incógnitas tremendas que se
demorarán muchos despejarse porque
además esto quiere decir lo que ha sido
muy ineficiente la gestión de juan puedo
a efectos de remover el al chavismo del
poder concretamente a maduro entonces no
se sabe tampoco cómo va a ser en la
cuantía de apoyo popular que va a
recibir en una llamada en una consulta
por venir el próximo 12 de diciembre no
que todo muy cierto 20 minutos el
resultado más notable es probablemente
la baja participación señora aquiles
este se ha reportado oficialmente que
apenas pasó del 30
tiene esto un impacto en la legitimidad
de los comicios bueno la legitimidad es
nula pero el régimen chavista no depende
de la legitimidad para mantenerse al
poder ellos necesitan de tiempo al
tiempo
poner en marcha estas elecciones buffaz
falsas que nadie respeta para darle un
barniz citó de la intimidad pero eso no
existe ya ya se sabe que si funcionan
las tiranías en todas parte del mundo de
tiempo en tiempo necesitan que los
electores virtuales no acudan a las
urnas de hecho ya publicaron unos
números
lo que yo han dicho a votar voto el 68
por ciento de la población una absoluta
barbaridad que por cierto coincide con
lo que es nicolás maduro en el año 2018
sé exactamente el 68 por ciento
me imagino que duplicarán es el número
bueno para darle un
para mí de validez a la lección del
detalle para una s con que se cuentan es
chupa el dedo las tomas de ayer sobre
todo las de twitter revelan las ciudades
vacías en rotación completamente vacío
ese es un país que está pasando todas
las calamidades y no tienen por qué ir a
votar con un parlamento en puesto de
ayer el jardín una parte importante de
la comunidad internacional ha criticado
el proceso electoral y eeuu y la unión
europea han dicho que no reconocen el
resultado señor aquiles este impacto
puede tener esto en la situación de
venezuela bueno la verdad
la situación de ayer lo que hace es
sincerar en opinión
condición de la presidencia interina de
one cuello que como decía más temprano
ha sido totalmente ineficiente a efecto
a remover a maduro del poder entonces
esta vez tenemos que esperar para ver
qué iba a hacer la unión europea
respecto del por cómo ha ido que el día
de ayer perdió su curul en el parlamento
venezolano entonces eso eso es una gran
incógnita no se sabe que va a ser él no
lo ha anunciado nuevamente el único que
ha anunciado en una consulta no
vinculante
esencialmente para apoyar bueno pero
también los números que han ofrecido las
encuestadoras son muy preocupantes
porque la participación en ese evento
electoral no llegaría a margo dígitos y
la verdad que tras valorar bien pues
muchas gracias por esta comunicación por
su análisis
aquiles este él es consultor y analista
en el mercado electoral quien se
encuentra en miami florida y muchas
gracias a ustedes por su compañía siga
con más mucho más en francés 24
[Música]